merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres merci j'ai une question
pour le ministre de l'économie vous avez
exquis et dans votre présentation près
de lui r d orientation pour le
rétablissement des finances publiques
moi je voulais vous vous interrogez sur
la fiscalité sur les successions c'est
qu'aujourd'hui l'héritage est un des
facteurs des inégalités les plus forts
en france il ya 10% des héritiers les
plus aisés qui vont concentrer 52% des
héritages quand les 50% et français les
plus pauvres ne toucheront rien
en france aujourd'hui il faut mieux être
riche
pour eux
pour être riche il vaut mieux hérité que
méritée si vous me permettez
l'expression
et je crois qu'il est il n'est pas
étrange est que ce débat prenne vie
durant la campagne présidentielle dans
la mesure où la question des inégalités
de plus en plus prégnante c'est ainsi
qu'il a été observé que les plus riches
héritiers bénéficie de multiples
transmission patrimoniale au cours de
leur vie et comme chaque transmission
est taxé séparément il est possible par
le jeu des différents dispositifs
fiscaux
d'optimiser ses transmissions bien que
des mesures étaient prises par le passé
pour tenter d'atténuer ce phénomène ce
soit la réduction du délai de rappel
fiscal et des abattements la
progressivité des taux d'imposition ce
sont finalement les petits transmission
qui ont été pénalisés
partant de ce constat le conseil
d'analysé économique invite à la mise en
place d'une assiette des droits fondés
sur la somme des flux successoraux
totaux perçue par un même individu tout
au long de sa vie dans ce système le
taux d'imposition dépendrait uniquement
de la valeur de l'héritage reçu
quelle que soit la façon dont le
patrimoine a été transmis donc la
question c'est est ce que vous ne pensez
pas que cette piste de réflexion devrait
faire l'objet d'une traduction
législative dans les dispositifs de nos
comptes publics